merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à la ministre de la cohésion
territoriale mais aussi peut s'adresser
à l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
et j'associe la députée Josso débute
Loire-Atlantique à cette question
algue verte c'est deux mots résonnent en
Bretagne depuis 60 ans
les gouvernements se sont succédés sans
pour autant résoudre totalement ce fléau
depuis les années 2000 des plans de
lutte contre les algues vertes associant
le milieu agricole ce sont succédé mais
n'ont pas évité des fermetures de plage
ou des accidents parfois dramatiques
pour les associations les médias ou des
députés en voyage nuptial C'est
l'occasion à chaque fois de dénoncer
l'inefficacité des collectivités de
l'état du monde agricole les désignants
systématiquement comme coupables dès
lors que cela devient devant la justice
comme la semaine dernière au tribunal
administratif de Rennes depuis 2021 et
le troisième plan de lutte contre les
algues vertes un sous-préfet a été nommé
pour la Bretagne et pour apporter des
solutions au monde à l'école et aux
collectivités
mais les moyens employés restent
insuffisants sont dignes du début du 20e
et pas du 21e siècle
l'absence de résultats tangent sur les
quantités d'algues vertes à de graves
conséquences en termes environnementales
économique ou de santé on sait
aujourd'hui qu'il faut déployer des
actions dans le domaine agricole la
recherche ou peut venir à bout de ce
fléau ainsi nous devons accompagner le
prof la profession agricole vers un
modèle vertueux au regard de l'étendue
du problème qu'une semaine limite plus à
la Bretagne vers un modèle
économiquement durable avec lequel nos
agriculteurs pourront vivre dignement et
effacer aussi cette image désastreuse
des marais vertes quelle action l'état
qu'on t'a apporté pour ne plus être dans
la réaction
pour rassurer les collectivités sur la
saison prochaine afin que ne soit pas à
nouveau amenées à fermer des plages
Madame le Ministre mon plus grand espoir
et que nous y arriverons enfin à marcher
sur toutes nos plages tout au long de
l'année je me demande pas de marcher sur
la lune mais juste que nous puissions
mener au moins une commission d'enquête
pour résoudre ce problème durablement
merci